to Justin Trudeau just a day or two ago
he's very worried about global
authoritarian leaders because obviously
irony is dead
the world today is facing a lot of
uncertainty with the rise in
authoritarian leaders causing Global
instability and the High Cost of Living
putting stress on families at home
he is just such a piece of work we
didn't have to dig too deep for this one
here's just one of the many moments of
Justin Trudeau being evil over the last
year or so
we are not intimidated
by those who hurl insults and abuse at
small business workers
and steal food
from the homeless
we won't give in
to those who fly racist Flags
we won't cave
to those who engage in vandalism
I had to write some of that down so
first off he's talking about the
truckers the truckers were insulting
small business owners the truckers were
small business owners you you you lizard
man you were the one that were locking
these people out of their jobs right
making sure that their kids couldn't go
to school they were the home the
truckers were stealing food from
homeless people like what in the world
does that mean generally homeless people
don't have a lot of food if you were
going to steal food from somebody you'd
go to Justin Trudeau's house because no
doubt he's got a whole freaking uh
refrigerator full of poutine
you know what poutine is it's like a
it's like a gravy that they put on their
french fries instead of ketchup it's
wild uh I don't like that guy I don't
like that guy
[Music]